a new survey is working to make sure
lgbtq kids are safe and understood a
civil rights organization in Nevada is
releasing the survey for those
struggling to speak out 8 news now
reporter Victoria Saha explains
Jessica Munger identifies as bisexual
growing up she says she didn't have many
people she could relate to it was
extremely hard and you know we didn't
have a smartphone and like all of these
online resources right available to us
the computers in the family room so it
was really different experience and
there was no GSA at school very limited
resources but now west program manager
for Silver State equality she wants to
make a difference in the lives of lgbtq
Youth the civil rights organization for
Nevada released a survey for youth who
identify as lgbtq specifically focusing
on their experiences in school our
administrators and teachers using the
correct pronouns are their spaces that
are designated like this is a safe space
for LGBT people are you learning about
LGBT stories research shows lgbtq youth
are four times more likely to attempt
suicide this survey will allow them to
stay Anonymous but be very honest about
what they're going through tell us how
you're feeling through the survey we
want to know so that we can help make
that better lean into Community allowing
them to feel a sense of belonging and
acceptance Victoria Saha 8 news now
directors plan to present the results to
legislatures and school administrators
to help advocate for inclusive programs
for all students